hi i'm cheryl and this is my glamofesto
for life
[Music]
my daily mantra is i am at peace i am
happy i am well
my instant mood booster is coffee
i am most looking forward to hugs
guilt-free hugs
lots of hugs just being able to bathe
with friends and family at will whenever
you want
the best thing that i've learned in the
past year is
having a break from social media is
really really healthy for your mind
what makes me feel passionate is helping
others
very passionate my one feel safe health
hack is
consistently supplementing daily
consistency is the keyword who or what
can i not live without i
am learning that i can be absolutely
fine
without anybody just me by myself i'm
learning to be happy just with me
what does glamour mean to me the most
glamorous beautiful people
are authentically themselves it's not
always about makeup or hair or the dress
it's about you being
beautifully you when do i feel the most
glam me personally i like to be dressed
up eyelashes
i feel the most glam when i have
something comfortable on an eyelash and
a nice hairdo the hair i think makes me
feel glamorous
who do i tune to for advice i'm learning
to tune to myself for advice
it's all in the process my biggest
achievement in the whole of life
is becoming a mother i deal with failure
by
learning from whatever mistake i made
the best way to clap back at misogyny is
to raise
a man that sees everybody equally man
and woman
and kills it in the world in that
mindset my current song of the moment
is jessie ware remember where you are
the one
book that changed my life is
dolores cannon new earth quirkiest thing
i do in the name of wellness
is i meditate for sometimes over an hour
i want my legacy to be that i
did enough in the world to help as many
others as i could
and that's my glamour festival for life